[Applause]
[Music]
i'm christopher hine and this week we're
talking about filling in all the missing
gaps in aikido
in the last video i talked a little bit
about one of our main goals in aikido
and that's the ability to be ahead to be
mentally ahead of what's going on
and how that can help us overcome
someone or at least manage and deal with
someone
who is bigger and stronger and faster
than us and wants to cause
trouble to us right so to be ahead and
being ahead
has a whole set of tactics that we'll
talk about that enable you to be ahead
right so all the little things you need
to do in order to be ahead
now one of the other important things if
we can't be ahead and there's lots of
times where we can't be ahead right we
got surprise all kinds of things can
happen
the next thing we want to do is to keep
a safe distance from someone so our
second main goal is to keep a safe
distance
now there's a minimum safe distance and
i've talked about that a lot in my
videos and that's just
that uh arm length distance right and
what's nice about that distance is
someone can't touch you without taking a
step first and that step
that they would take gives you enough
reaction time that you could deal with
it right you could defend
yourself against it or attack them back
or get out of there all kinds of other
stuff can happen
so that's a really important distance
now other distances are also available
to us right long distances are good as
well
so understanding how to manage distance
now this managing distance again will
lead us to another set of tactics that
we'll need to understand
to manage the distance so how do we
manage the distance
and then the interplay between distance
and headedness also is a set of tactics
right meaning
that i can use distancing as a tactic
to get back ahead right meaning if
someone's coming to attack me
and i can create a little distance so
they can't get to me i can start to
think okay this person's coming towards
me and they're coming like this and this
is the surroundings we're in and so i
can do
these kinds of things to prevent them
from getting me right so
i can actually use distancing as a
tactic
to achieve my goal so i believe that
distancing
is a goal in aikido so it's something to
be achieved and if i'm achieving
distance
then i'm achieving my aikido goals which
lead to my philosophy
but it's also a tactic in and of itself
to help me
get ahead again which is one of my
biggest goals right to be ahead
now another main goal of aikido that
also can be used as a tactic with the
rest of these
is the ability to position yourself uh
in an ideal position right so if we just
looked at two bodies
the most ideal position for you to be in
if someone was attacking you
is to be behind them so that's the best
position the worst position for you to
be in
would be uh right in front of them with
your back to them right so the exact
flip-flop of that is the worst position
for you
so understanding what position is and
what are good positions in bad positions
is another main goal in aikido we always
want to be in the good position the best
position available to us
and that again will lead to another set
of tactics that help us
maintain good position and positioning
again
is itself a tactic to help us achieve
distance
and to help us achieve being ahead so we
can use these three goals right which
are
basically positioning distancing
and the ability to be ahead of someone
we can use those
as not only just goals to be achieved on
themselves but also as tactics
to help us achieve our philosophy so the
the the relationship between tactics and
and goals is really really close the
goal is just
the goal am i far away from them or do i
have a good position on them
or am i ahead of them those are just the
goals right but how do we get
to that goal is another thing right so
and that's the tactics how do i achieve
that goal that's the actual tactics
and then those goals being ahead can
allow me to
keep my distance or being at distance
can allow me to get ahead
and so those three co-mingle in this
interesting way
so those are the three goals and also
they tell us what the three main sets of
tactics are and there's more tactics of
course that would go to those
but those are our set of tactics now
down from this
we'll go into techniques and that gets
into a little more familiar territory
for most aikido
practitioners but so remember our main
idea here is we have a philosophy
then we have goals that let us know if
we're achieving our philosophy
and then tactics right and these tactics
start to
give us what our overall strategy or
system is and then below that are the
techniques and the techniques are the
immediate actions we take
in order to implement our tactics
i'm christopher hine check out the next
video we'll see you soon